good all right here are the questions
from the people in their underwear
Anthony which Democratic presidential
candidate should Trump fear the most so
I'm probably little different from
governor mcauliffe I would be going
younger with somebody like Senator
Harris or mayor Pete Budaj and I think
that that contrast okay the thing I've
tried say last time here on the show go
out there and speak to the people that
Trump won last time don't call them the
pourable or white nationalist go out
there and understand what they're what's
wrong with their economic situation and
boy let me tell you something that would
be very powerful if Democrats in my
opinion always do better when they go
with somebody below the age of 50 well
hire Obama John Kennedy Bill Clinton
back in the 90s okay be me go for
somebody younger
Catherine what's your reaction to Beto
saying what the [ __ ] to the press in
regards to their coverage of Trump's
racism I think that was a perfectly
valid response frankly I think that was
in response to the question do you think
Trump is a white supremacist or a white
nationalist or something like that and
like yes obviously and it's not just
because of stuff he said this week and
it's not just because he refused to rent
to black tenants in the 70s the result
so him saying that the central Central
Park five should be executed and still
refusing to back down from that
birtherism you know Muslim ban all that
other stuff okay long history richard
engel why is Trump harsh on China except
when it comes to the pro-democracy
protests in Hong Kong and while in there
lately that's pretty nasty I you know
it's it's very troubling I think he
doesn't bother him he's made it quite
clear that human rights groups when they
are in protesters when they come out on
the streets that's not a priority for
him and I think he respects people who
have power and use power and the reason
I'm worried about what's going on in
Hong Kong there is a very high cost to
failure so these people have come out on
the sir
if they don't succeed and don't succeed
in establishing the the rights and the
laws that they're they're pushing for
they could pay a very very high price
like a Tiananmen Square
mikage animus well Trump raised the
Chinese response to Tiananmen Square as
you may recall he's not hard to get on
your side if you just say quite handsome
Governor Terry as someone who turned a
red state blue do you think Democrats
have a real shot at Texas in 2020 yes I
do I think look at the polls today I
mean listen the big issue is who has the
best chance of defeating Trump right now
it's Biden right now on the point date
it can change we got six months to go
before the primary start but today Biden
pola know how he beats Trump by eight
points in Ohio he wins Georgia he wins
North Carolina and he wins Texas today
against Donald Trump so we got a great
opportunity you know Trump's gonna
continue to do the insanity that he does
every single day he can't get over 42%
he's alienated most of America he's got
his base and I'm just shocked he's
coming out and doing all these things
against Elijah Cummings the squad I
guess he figures they're all these
neo-nazis and white supremacist under
rocks that weren't motivated in 2016 and
they're gonna come out in 2020
he is alienated non-college educated
white women they walk down we have a
good Japanese I think you just did what
Hillary did last time when she said to
floor but it sounded to some people like
you called everyone who voted horrible
Nazis under rocks it's a thing it's a
big black rose but that is not what it
sounded like you say these are bad I
know but then every person who voted for
Trump is not a neo-nazi under Iraq
nobodies why is he doing us I'm he's
trying to spur a new base for him no no
who's he talking to when he attacks
Elijah Cummings clay that's more
rat-infested I am Mississippi Gulf
country get it these women were born in
this country
Trump bed are you good
thank you home you see why I only
watched Brian Williams I just okay Tom
your book is called the death of
expertise what is the solution Wow and
yeah in 30 seconds Tom I think the
problem is people the problem with the
death of expertise is that it again it's
written in narcissism it's not that
people need more education they we mean
not just his everyone know everybody
knows not the only narcissist in this
country that is true everyone does it to
each other people will walk up to you
know you and say oh you're a stand-up
comedian I have some thoughts on timing
right no it's too right now you know
governor here's here's what you should
do about the budget yeah do that because
it feels empowering and it makes them
feel important and I think we're just
gonna have to wait for that bubble to
burst where we we have to start
listening to each other because we're
heading for disaster and I think it
could be that recession or a war I the
three things I worry about our pandemic
a recession or a war and any one of
those things if people are gonna start
listening to doctors economists and
generals again except to play devil's
advocate we had a Great Recession and
what happened people stopped trusting
economists right there are a lot of
economists who don't focus on financial
markets but sudden who in fact said
we're quite worried about you know for
not trusting economists I think they
stopped trusting capitalists yeah
anchors yes okay well maybe I don't know
if people ever had an idea in their mind
about economists one right there to
begin right maybe the people you hang
out but I'm talking about the regular
rank-and-file
I think they blame the banksters well
because they say the bankers were
experts and they told me I could afford
it no the banker is an expert the same
way that a Lexus salesman is a Lexus
expert who says you can afford this car
right that's the that's different than
an economist saying you know running up
your household debt to massive levels on
a house you know that you shouldn't have
bought in the first place is a bad idea
and that's all those guys don't know
there was a lot of pushback against the
Fed the Fed made mistakes but the Fed
also bailed our asses out the experts
let us know it did
yes yeah and I think Tom points that out
in his book his book is great but would
happen well
the experts the establishment pato like
some economists said we're going off a
cliff and we're we're plating my bubble
and the collective Society of s experts
again lower middle class people middle
class people feel that the establishment
positions abandoned them and that's why
you've had this politicians are not the
same people this is the other problem I
was a senior adviser to us to a u.s.
senator
sometimes he took my advice sometimes he
threw me out of his office
the idea that while the elite I mean
look in the Senate me in the senator I
was the expert
he was the elite he got to vote I was
just the guy who came I mean you have
people advise you all day governor right
yeah you know in the end it's yours the
senator the late john hines pennsylvania
oh good man ketchup guy trump ran on
draining the swamp which i think to most
people man get rid of the you know pom
greasing executives and the lobbyists
and the corrupt officials and and all of
those other people who are getting rich
off of government and instead what it
has turned out to mean is let's pardon
rod Blagojevich and purge all the
scientists which is exactly what Trump
either has said he is considered doing
or is actually doing but that piece you
guys had today about purging the experts
that is a huge issue that's going on
right now and the federal government
basically the Republicans have decided
that anybody who knows stuff has to
leave exactly what's happening we hope
they'll come here and join our panel
thank you very much everybody
[Applause]
you